tori is with us in Kansas City starting
off this hour hi Tori how are you
I gave I'm well how are you happy Friday
happy Friday to you how can I help well
I have a question I am new to prayer in
finding my faith and everything and I'm
wondering how do you pray for a
financial help or assistance without
feeling selfish every time I try to I
just feel like okay there's more
important stuff going on in the world I
should be praying for that verses help
with my debt snowball it's a good
question
the scripture says that if we being evil
know how to give our get kids good gifts
how much more so our Father in Heaven
and so yeah there's a whole lot more
important things than your debt snowball
or my gas tank on my truck being full
running around out there but the truth
is God so infinitely wise and powerful
that he can handle the little stuff and
the big stuff so it's not selfish at all
the thing I have always done as I'm have
matured in my faith I mean when I first
started I just said like God I need some
money I mean I need some help I got to
pay the light bill I got hungry kid over
here you know I mean I would just ask
straight up like that and there's
nothing wrong with that if you're you
know just taking care of your family or
your basic needs or something along
those lines and then the other part of
it is as I asked for two other things as
I got a little bit older one was wisdom
so that show me in your word what to do
so that I can change and align my self
with that rather than you just you know
showing up at the front door with an
Amazon box full of whatever right and
show me it show me how to live in other
words because he's more concerned with
our character than he is our
circumstances does that make sense and
so you know give me wisdom God's people
suffer for lack of knowledge the
scripture says and so if we can you know
give me wisdom show me what you want me
to do show me how you
to live and then usually that starts to
give you the tools to solve money issues
you know that and so you start to learn
what the Bible says about money like
staying out of debt the borrower's slave
to the lender having a budget don't
build a tower without first counting the
cost saving money in the house of the
wise or stores of choice food and oil
and so you start to get biblical wisdom
and it applies in your life and changes
your character changes your maturity and
you learn to say okay I'm gonna delay
pleasure no discipline seems Pleasant at
the time because of you but it yields a
harvest of righteousness Bible says in
Hebrews and so you start to learn you
know that that's God's Word that's him
speaking to me through his love letter
right and and so I asked for him to just
keep feeding me those things so that he
changed me God to who you want me to be
to solve this problem and that kind of
falls under the heading not of God
solving the problem but the you know
sambro said you work like it all depends
on you and you pray like it all depends
on him and and so the farmer doesn't
just pray he he also plants he puts seed
in the ground he plows and gets the
weeds out of the field right and then
and he also praised because he needs
sunshine and rain in the perfect
proportion to have a bumper crop so and
then the last thing I learned was from a
good friend of mine who's an Orthodox
Jewish rabbi rabbi Daniel lapin and he
wrote a wonderful book called thou shall
prosper which is why Jewish people have
a tendency to prosper and it was a
little bit of a twist on hard work for
me I've always been taught to work hard
you probably were too Tori you know that
works where money comes from and all
that kind of stuff but he said that she
says in this book and again he and I
become friends over the years
he said the Jewish mindset is don't ask
for money ask for an opportunity to
serve someone how give me a problem I
can solve for someone and by the way
they'll give you money when you do that
you know what I'm saying so it leads to
money but rather than Lord give me give
me a job instead no give me an
opportunity to help someone
and it bring economic value to them and
then want to give me their money you
know in other words if you're going if
you're standing around in a restaurant
and it's empty what you're praying for
is I need people at these tables so that
I have someone to serve and if I serve I
get tips you see the little twist on
that it's more than just give me work
it's give me an opportunity to serve
help someone because money generally is
attached to that and so that's the kind
of thing I've done over the years I mean
just to you that's a really great
question to open up the hour with thank
you
and so wisdom an opportunity to serve as
I twist on the classic work ethic you
know those that won't work don't let
them eat that kind of thing is
scriptural so you know you got your part
to play in this in other words and but
but ask him to guide you in that give me
opportunities give me a favor if I'm
going in to sit down and talk to someone
about an extra job to make some extra
money to pay off my dad you know because
the time the number of times he just
bundles up money and puts it in an
Amazon box and drops it at the front
door is almost zero that's why they call
it miracles when because it's so rare
instead he usually changes us and
redirects our journey where the path he
wants us on for our own good just like
when you're ready if you're raising kids
you're showing your kid you know I love
my kid and if me wanting my kid to win
if I get that how much more so god
that's what the Bible starts with so he
wants good things for you he's crazy
about you but it's usually not a
heavenly handout if that makes any sense
yeah absolutely thank you so much for
your insight that that really helps me
cool was it great thank you for letting
me have a discussion with you on it it's
a something fun to talk about because
there's this interaction you know the
rest of you out there and just kind of
staying on this for a second
there's kind of two ends of the spectrum
in Christianity and that are both wrong
the middle of the spectrum is actually
right but there's the end of spectrum
that says you know you should never have
wealth
anyone who has any material goods you
know you should be poor if you're a
Christian and then there's the other end
of spectrum that says if you just pray
God will just rain money on you and that
all Christians should you know have
perfect health and all Christians should
have unlimited resources and prosperity
both of those are toxic untruth toxic
heritage they're really heresy when you
really get down into what they are
because of because what they're doing is
is they're they're twisting the
relationship with your heavenly father
and so it from a theological or a
doctrinal standpoint that's what you get
into so but this balance between you
know work like it all depends on you
pray like it all depends on God so we
understand it's sovereignty we
understand it's Providence we understand
he's in control we understand anything
loves us we also understand we have a
part to play in this life and so you
know you get up and get moving and
that's how it mixes in great great
question for you thanks for letting me
talk about it